disputed news in terms of the number of
police officers dead we're hearing to
potentially three what's the latest yeah
that's that's exactly where it is right
now the city of Baton Rouge mayor of the
mayor office officially reported to
there is CNN is pushed out three and and
we're hearing from some of our sources
it's very well maybe three but we have
not heard that officially from our city
government still an active situation
apparently one shooter down and this has
happened all in kind of the same area
about the boundary city police
headquarters just moved about a year ago
order to this area airline highway and
all this shooting if what-have-you is
within a half mile of the police
department and then it actually crossed
a major intersection and went behind a
convenience store and so informations
been tough because it is a Sunday
morning and everyone I'm a little a
little bit from what we understand seven
officers have been shot two are deceased
possibly a third so did he say that
there was one shooter that was down from
we've heard the police scanners one
shooters down one shooter still active
so at least to the best of our knowledge
well give us a little bit of an idea
what the situation is like in Baton
Rouge and we have been reporting
extensively on the shooting of a molten
Sterling earlier this month I mean what
what else is like before his shooting
dead by police and and since then well
you know I actually flew back I was out
on the west coast the United States for
a week and I flew back in and there were
some demonstrations last weekend a lot
of the people that were arrested I'd say
90% of them were from outside the
battery city limits a lot of people came
in that I guess were professional or
active and wanted to have their voices
heard and and so we felt like there was
a lot of outside influence coming into
the city and it was a relatively calm
week here in Baton Rouge other than they
vanished police and some federal
authorities spoiled a plot to shoot some
officers in which they found some people
that robbed the pawn shop were able to
get a lead and arrested and apprehended
people that was earlier in the week but
it's been really quiet so I will tell
you that this activity this morning
definitely comes as a surprise because I
think most people are thought that
things would remain quiet until some
sort of arraignment charges of the
federal investigation on the offense
darling you know the shooting that the
reports came out whether or not they
would arrange the the officer or not and
obviously that was not the case now we
have heard the mayor of the area Kip
Holden come out to call in the on the
community to forgive him if you saying
that there was actually already another
plot aimed and targeted at police
if this something you could have
foreseen coming do you think this is
something that was brewing essentially
in the area it's always possible in this
day and age but you know as I'm I told
you there was the one we thought this
was an isolated incident involved a pawn
shop a robbery of a pawn shop and like I
said that one was holding and that was
maybe Tuesday of this week and the last
four days have been relatively quiet and
I think the community the community
leaders religious leaders everybody had
been vocal to if you're gonna protest
protest peacefully let's wait and let's
see what the outcome of this federal
investigation is before anyone takes any
more major steps or gets out of line so
this this does come as a surprise
typically I will tell you total surprise
no but they're definitely surprised
well obviously and there are fears that
indeed a man is on the loose the man
behind the shooting is on the loose what
is the situation like there for you now
what what is the atmosphere like right
now well I will tell you that you know
Sunday morning a lot of people obviously
a church and just getting news of this
people maybe sleep a little late there
there's a major portion of banner
erosion this is a right in the heart of
the city it's the adjacent to an
interstate so the off ramps and on ramps
of this interstate is shut down and I
would say for about a two mile 2x2 mile
area it's blocked off and so you can't
get in or out and I can tell you my
community here I saw at least 12 local
area office
I'm talking about fringe communities
what have you jetting to this location
so there's no shortage of police and
officials on hand and I think everybody
staying inside until they get the
all-clear that this is no longer an
active situation as everything we've
heard before I walked into the studio to
speak with you it's still an active
situation